the Joe Rogan experience what did you
think of the Joker okay I have to break
the Joker down because I know a lot of
people that are moralistically very
against it yes you know my generation is
really mad at it
I thought as a movie that movie was
really badass that movie was I thought
it was really good
masterpiece masterpiece oh my god those
sequences and the going down the stairs
and the music choices that was a
masterpiece it was amazing I loved it
now the the other this other unit that
you you know if there if the movies
broken down into two units the one is
the master the masterpiece we're calling
of the movie itself and then what's you
know what are the themes that are giving
life to this movie or the purpose or
what are this what's the purpose I mean
you could go well that could be you know
that you know there could be some bad
stuff in there you know or but I'm not
deep enough to know I could identify it
exactly and having made so many movies I
can't be judgmental of it I liked it and
so I just feel like people in glass
houses shouldn't throw stones I think
that's a good way of looking at and how
do you see it can you ask I thought it
was brilliant but very disturbing yeah
but it was supposed to be disturbing
yeah I think they accomplished their
goal you know with flying colors I think
it was a very very unusual movie very
difficult to find any parallels with any
other previous movie exactly I thought
it was [ __ ] amazing
yeah then when I left I didn't feel good
yeah I didn't feel like that it was like
wow I'm going to party great yeah yeah I
was like [ __ ] I walked out of the
theater like [ __ ] yeah it just blows you
away yeah no good and me and my wife
talked about it for a long time
yeah was she honest she loved it oh but
she it's not her kind of movie yeah but
it was there was something about it it
was so well executed and Joaquin Phoenix
was amazing it was kind of operatic and
somehow I mean we're the music and
everything
yeah I mean the build-up to it too there
was so much going on and so much madness
and yeah he understood you you felt
empathy for this guy who was ultimately
a monster and a murderer yes spoiler
alert but I felt you felt for him yeah
you know I mean in that sense they they
managed to navigate those incredibly
treacherous waters brilliantly yeah I
thought it was [ __ ] awesome yeah good
me too
no I mean that directors great yeah no
he's great do you Phillips I'm sure you
know him but don't I hope friends who
know him yeah yeah my friend Bryan
Callen he was in The Hangover and he's
in I was in this movie briefly too yeah
okay but I don't know yeah so that's
that
[Applause]